Sa kabanatang ito, bibigyan natin ng balangkas
kung paano mag-isip tungkol sa mga computer environment
na magagamit sa iyong laptop
hanggang sa malalaking supercomputer
sa katapusan ng kabanatang ito
maiintindihan mo ang pangunahing konsepto ng computer resources
at kung paano sila magkakaugnay
kaya ano nga ba ang computer resources? simple lang —
mga bahagi na bumubuo ng isang computer system
mayroon tayong CPU o central processing unit
na nagpapatakbo ng karamihan sa mga instruksyon, at mayroon din tayong memory
o RAM na pansamantalang nag-iimbak ng data
at ng mga instruksyon ng programa
at mayroon din tayong mga GPU o graphics processing unit
na dinisenyo para sa graphics rendering
pero maaari ding gamitin para sa general-purpose computing tasks
na nangangailangan ng maraming parallel processing
tulad ng scientific simulation, data analytics, o machine learning
ang mga resources na ito ay nagtutulungan para patakbuhin ang mga programa
at bawat isa ay may sariling unit ng pagsukat
halimbawa, ang CPU ay sinusukat sa bilang ng cores
at clock speed, habang ang memory naman ay sinusukat sa bytes
sa giga, mega, at terabytes
para sa bawat problema natin
kakailanganin natin ng set ng resources
para maipatupad ang mga ito
mahalagang isaalang-alang ang resources na kailangan para patakbuhin ang mga ito
nang mahusay — ang lokasyon kung saan pinapatakbo ang mga bahagi ng programa
at ang bandwidth ng imprastraktura na nagkokonekta sa kanila
ay malaking papel na ginagampanan
sa pagtukoy ng kabuuang performance
halimbawa, maaaring mas mabilis ang GPU sa pagkalkula ng ilang bahagi
ng ating programa, pero kung ang pag-load ng programa sa memory ng GPU
ay mas matagal kaysa sa ating matitipid
maaaring mas mabilis pang gumamit ng CPU sa halip. ngayon
pag-usapan natin ang pag-scale ng classical resources
mayroon tayong dalawang paraan: vertical scaling
at horizontal scaling. ang vertical scaling ay nangangahulugang pagpapalakas
ng isang resource
tulad ng paggamit ng mas makapangyarihang CPU o mas maraming memory
sa loob ng iisang physical node
kung saan ang node ay isang unit ng compute cluster na naglalaman ng maraming
resources. ang horizontal scaling naman
ay pagdaragdag ng mas maraming resources
tulad ng maraming CPU o GPU
na magtutulungan sa iisang node o sa maraming node
pareho ay may kani-kanilang mga kalamangan
at kahinaan, at ang pagpili ay nakasalalay sa partikular na use case
at mga pangangailangan. ngayon, ipakilala natin ang bagong uri ng resource:
quantum resources. ang quantum resources ay nagpoproseso ng quantum information
sa pamamagitan ng quantum processing unit o QPU. ang QPU
ay ang buong sistema na responsable
sa pagtanggap ng executable quantum instruction set
o quantum circuit at pagbabalik ng
tumpak na sagot. ibig sabihin
ang QPU ay kinabibilangan ng isa o higit pang quantum chip
halimbawa, isang IBM quantum processor
pati na rin ang maraming karagdagang komponente
sa loob ng isang dilution refrigerator
na nagpapalamig sa quantum chip
tulad ng quantum amplifier, control electronics
at ang classical computer na kailangan
para sa mga gawain tulad ng pag-iimbak ng mga instruksyon
at waveforms sa memory, pag-iipon ng mga resulta
at sa hinaharap, error correction decoding
sa pangkalahatan, ang quantum resources ay sinusukat
sa pamamagitan ng kalidad nito, ang layer fidelity scale
ang bilang ng quantum bits
at ang bilis — ang circuit layer operations per
second o CLOPS. ngayon, ituturing natin ang quantum chip
bilang unit ng pagsukat, katulad ng paraan ng pamamahala ng resource management systems
sa mga GPU — hindi sa bilang ng cores
kundi bilang buong unit. paano naman ang scaling?
tulad ng classical resources, ang pag-scale ng quantum resources ay maaari rin
na ikategorya sa vertical
at horizontal. ang vertical scaling
ay pagdaragdag ng bilang ng qubits bawat chiplet
o bawat chip
habang ang horizontal scaling ay pagkonekta ng mga chip
sa pamamagitan ng couplers o classical interconnects
ngayong malinaw na ang mga kahulugan
pag-usapan natin ang resource management
ang resource management sa computer infrastructure ay tumutukoy
sa proseso ng pagpaplano
pag-allocate, at pagkontrol sa paggamit ng computational resources
tulad ng CPU, memory, storage
at network bandwidth para masigurado ang mahusay
at epektibong paggamit ng resources
maaari mong isipin ang resource management
bilang isang multi-dimensional na laro ng Tetris kung saan ang mga bloke
ay ang mga kinakailangan ng iyong trabaho
at bawat dimensyon ay isang resource unit. ang pangkalahatang gawain
ay ang pagsiksik ng mga bloke ng trabaho sa cube na
kumakatawan sa lahat ng available na resources. ang resource management
ay napakahirap na gawain at iba't ibang compute facility ang gumagamit ng
iba't ibang paraan para i-configure ang kanilang imprastraktura
ayon sa partikular na pangangailangan ng kanilang mga gumagamit
para mailapat ang mga konseptong natutunan natin, gagamit tayo ng
Slurm. ang Slurm ay open-source na software
para sa resource management
para sa demonstrasyon, mayroon ako
ng lokal na setup na may tatlong virtual node
makukuha natin ang impormasyon tungkol sa mga computer node na iyon
sa pamamagitan ng pagpapatakbo ng scontrol command
mayroon tayong dalawang partition o grupo ng node:
normal at quantum. ang normal na partition ay binubuo ng mga node
na may access sa classical resources lamang
at ang quantum partition naman ay may access sa quantum resources
una, patakbuhin natin ang simpleng
classical hello world na halimbawa gamit ang Slurm
una, kailangan natin ng hello world program mismo.
At nandito na ang ating programa na nagpi-print lang ng hello
world.
Ngayon, kailangan nating sabihin sa resource manager
kung anong resources ang kailangan natin para patakbuhin ang programang ito
tulad ng napag-usapan natin, nagbibigay ang Slurm ng paraan para tukuyin
ang lahat ng metadata ng trabaho sa pamamagitan ng
isang batch script
na simpleng shell script lang
na may ilang Slurm-specific na annotations
ang mga annotation na ito ay nagbibigay-daan sa iyo na tukuyin ang resource requirements
scheduling parameters, at iba pa.
Maaari nating tingnan ang ating submission script
at makikita mo doon ang partition specification
kung ilang node ang kailangan natin, ilang task bawat node ang papatakbuhin
at ilang CPU bawat task ang gagamitin natin
at kung aling script ang ating patatakbuhin
at ito ang ating hello world program.
Para isumite ang ating trabaho para sa pagpapatakbo, isa lang ang command na kailangan natin:
ang sbatch
at ibigay ang ating script bilang argument
maaari nating tingnan ang execution queue
at makikita natin na tumatakbo na ang ating hello world program
sa normal na partition sa node c1
pagkatapos matapos ang trabaho, maaari na nating tingnan ang mga resulta
sa pamamagitan ng pagtingin sa output file.
At ganoon na lang.
Interesado rin tayo sa paggamit ng quantum resources
kaya naman gumawa tayo ng simpleng hello Qiskit na programa.
Nandito ang ating Qiskit program na naglalaman ng lahat ng
kinakailangang hakbang ng paggawa ng circuit
pag-optimize, pagpapatakbo, at post-processing.
At nandito ang lahat ng programming concept na pinag-usapan natin:
quantum circuit, transpiler
at ang Qiskit primitives
ngayon kailangan nating gumawa ng submission script
tulad ng dati, pero dito naman ay tutukuyin natin
ang quantum resources requirements
dahil tinukoy na natin ang mga resources
at ang partition sa ating cluster
anong quantum resources ang available
ang Qiskit primitives ang gagamit
ng na-allocate na resources para patakbuhin ang quantum computations.
Ngayon, kailangan na nating patakbuhin ang ating programa.
At pagkatapos matapos ang trabaho, maaari na nating tingnan ang mga resulta.
At nandito na ang ating expectation value.
At iyon na ang resource management
sa susunod na seksyon ay pag-uusapan natin
ang mga programming model